[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
let's do this
yeah
well that is that was too much what I do
not know now what I did was a little
muddled me I'm sorry you come out is so
clear that you because I've talked to
you so many times it's so clear when you
come out and there's an audience you
love being Will Smith you enjoy it I
love it
you were doing
[Music]
right you're not shy being Denzel a
couple days just a lot of energy yeah no
I love my life man I'm having such a
good time you know you know there's so
many people that are curious what is
this movie about in your best what's
your best description brief description
of what this movie is all about you know
it's funny it's really difficult we all
read it and we loved it and we like yeah
we want to make it right but it's I
guess the best way that I can describe
it imagine like like training day right
like the energy of training day David
Rohde training day right yep so yeah
pretty good energy of training day so
got it so it's like the energy of
training day meets Lord of the Rings got
it right yeah
yeah so like imagine like Lord of the
Rings was like 4,000 years ago yeah but
then the creatures came forward into
present day and now we're in gritty
grimy present-day Los Angeles right but
there's orcs and stuff running over
right that's just a smidgen of home
alone is in there yeah yeah yeah I'm
curious I'm just curious what you're
gonna do because you have this famous
tradition if you like to see a movie in
the theater when it opens this is on
Netflix what are you going to do what do
you how do you do that yeah that's a
little different that's a little
different you know because it's been a
big thing you know when I would have Big
Willy weekend and all that type of stuff
I had a big Willy week
you're gonna have to break into
someone's mouth yeah that didn't go well
I'm out right I didn't go well at all
yeah so what are you gonna do you can't
see the theater so you know it'll be
like home business oh yeah you just go
to people's house you go to people's
house with you guys the whole cast
should go to people's homes yeah looking
gonna be like this like imagine you
watching the film so you're looking for
were you watching the movie watching the
movie after the movie going in I'm
having a good time on Netflix singing
I'm chill and then I'll send really good
yeah good job fantastic
you